well after decades of denial and secrecy
and flat-out lying America's defense
establishment is finally admitting some
of what it knows about UFOs the Navy has
admitted that it's pilots encounter
unidentified aircraft so often that
they've had to draft new reporting
guidelines to allow pilots to come
forward it's easy to find this funny but
it's also scary if you think about it
our vast well-funded defense
establishment is seeing things in the
sky they cannot account for doing things
they cannot understand should we be
worried congressman mark Walker's
Republican representing the state of
North Carolina he just sent a letter to
the Secretary of the Navy Richard
Spencer about the military's UFO
investigations we recently spoke to the
congressman here's part of what he said
should we be worried about this well we
we are concerned about it as the ranking
member of terrorism and
counterintelligence we have questions it
comes down to some of the new infrared
radar 'test systems that we're putting
on some of our new jets are detecting
some things out there we call them
unidentified aerial threats and that's
something that we're looking at are you
ApS is what we call it we want to know
the information and that's why it's
important that we take a look at this so
there's been going on an awfully long
time there's a lot of data the
government have has stored about this
most of it I think is still classified
but there must be theories about what
these objects are what these aircraft
are what's the most plausible theory do
you think well we don't know for sure
obviously what we do know is the
question that we're wanting to get to is
is this something that's a defense
mechanism from another country we do
know that China is looking at hypersonic
missiles that's 25,000 kilometers or to
break it down into our language that's
getting from DC where I'm head to LA in
about nine minutes we don't know that
the nuclear warheads can be attached to
those is it something like that or is it
something more we don't know but I feel
like it's something that we must take a
look at and that's why we've written
secretary Spencer of the Navy is there
any indication that you're aware of that
these sightings are foreign aircraft
Russian or Chinese aircraft
we don't know what we have no evidence
to support that we do know there's
something that's traveling at that speed
of what we call hypersonic now which is
a Mach four or five not too technical
that is something that we want to know
is this something that that another
defense system in another country is
more advanced or is it something else
we're not trying to spook people out but
the a the AAT IP which basically a
program that the government monitors
this was to close down in 2017 so part
of my question Tucker is it really
closed down are we still spending
resources or is there more documentation
that this program is still being able to
file somewhere that's that's something
that we need to know even if it's just
for defense purposes alone we spoke to a
government employee who has worked on
this issue who said that the u.s.
government has wreckage from one of
these aircraft do you know anything
about that we don't know but that's one
of the four questions that we are asking
is there evidence being held somewhere
not to get 2spooky once again but if
there is evidence I believe it's
important for people specifically in my
position as the ranking member of
terrorism and counterintelligence we
need to know what this is of course
that's and those are all legitimate
questions every rifle that you're not
being a bullied or mocked into not
asking them please I hope you'll come
back and tell us what the answers are we
look forward when we find out they're
coming back Thank You Tucker